watch this
i changed the world
[Music]
i didn't mean to but i did and when you
do something that big you make friends
and you make enemies
and that's okay i go to bed every night
knowing that what i've done has always
been for the right purpose for the right
reason
i'm russ kenshur and i'm the guy that
kind of invented or developed the slip
and fall prevention industry
russell kenzier is an expert witness he
also runs a nonprofit called the
national floor safety institute and he's
based in texas this is something i put
my entire
background and experience in and maybe
more importantly my family's wealth i
don't know how many lives
i've saved
but there's got to be a lot of them
there's got to be a lot of people today
who
haven't fallen or died or just been
injured because they walked on a floor
that was protected
this is a story on the micro scale about
friction that's the friction between the
bottom of your foot and a floor or
walkway surface but on the macro level
it's also about the
contention or the debate about how you
measure that friction
there are many players with vested
interest in this and there are competing
ways to measure the friction of a floor
manufacturers of floors don't want
liability
no offense but if your mother falls your
grandmother falls or somebody comes into
your store and falls and gets hurt they
don't really care
i'm just being honest the manufacturers
of floors could care less they just
don't want to get sued
there are no national standards for
measuring the coefficient of friction
for walkway surfaces which is the
technical way of saying how slippery a
floor is private industry really in
every aspect of industry whatever
manufactured product they're perfectly
capable of coming up with safety
standards in reporting this story i
certainly came away with the impression
that russell cansor sees this as a
crusader standing up to big floor
falling is something of an epidemic in
the united states
it's one of the leading causes of
preventable injuries and costs tens of
billions of dollars annually
flooring rhymes with boring and i think
that most people don't care about it but
at the same time it's right under our
feet every day
everybody likes a shiny floor the floor
maintenance industry has invested
billions and billions of dollars over
decades through marketing efforts to to
get us to understand that shiny means
good
when you start to walk you're basically
creating a series of micro slips
if that microscope turns into a macro
slip and you keep slipping you're not
able to use postural control to then do
the next step and the next step if you
keep slipping you're going to fall the
slip becomes a slide and slide becomes a
ball
baby boomers i'm one of them retiring at
a rate of ten thousand a day and what's
the leading cause of injury for the baby
boomers
slips trips and falls
slip trip and falls are a source of a
lot of litigation they're also
often seen as the source of frivolous
litigation traditionally retailers
haven't taken this seriously because
composite vinyl tiles are very cheap and
they cover acres of flooring in the
united states and would be very
expensive to fix
companies are paying tens of billions of
dollars in claims litigation it's just a
common problem and so you do the math
and say well how many people are going
into a walmart or a costco pick a large
retail store the cost of fixing the
problem to many of these companies is
far more expensive than the cost of
paying claims
russell kensior got his start as one of
five children outside of chicago
graduated college and became a floor
salesman in the dallas area as part of
that job he started hearing from
customers that people were falling and
getting hurt on the floors and he would
call the company and say you know what
should i tell these people and according
to russ the company basically told him
we can't help you you should just tell
them to call our lawyers he thought that
was really odd so he eventually quit
after running a floor cleaning business
for a while he got a call from a lawyer
who asked him about testifying as an
expert witness so he started working as
a consultant i'm not an advocate for
plaintiff's
attorneys or defense attorneys i'm a
safety guy floor safety begins with the
floor and prior to the national floor
safety institute publishing standards
the flooring industry really didn't have
any standards for slip resistance
russell kensior is a very persuasive
person because he's so persuasive i
think he's made a lot of enemies mr
kansiar earns his
living as a forensic consultant so that
was a little bit of a problem for us
forensic consultants aren't absolutely
looking for a standard they're looking
for a unique solution that they can sell
my name is peter ermesh i'm the
president of walkway management group
that is a new company founded three
years ago
committed to helping to solve the
problem of slip and fall injuries in our
society
we became deeply involved in creating
international standards that would solve
the mystery of slips and falls and make
it really a black and white issue that
would allow people at every level
to monitor the safety of their floors
and solve the hazard problem if they
detected one
triboluminescence is a phenomena that
describes the the spark of light that's
created by friction
[Music]
a tribometer is a instrument that's used
to measure friction
these tend to look like car battery type
boxes
others are sort of sleds that you drag
across the floor
some of the tribometers in europe are
actually
inclined slopes
there's also some that kind of resemble
like
feet
there are a lot of different tools for
measuring friction and not all of them
come up with the same same reading
some organizations including russell
kensior's organization have put forward
standards for measuring the friction of
floors
but there's also sort of no
standard for developing standards and in
the united states the development of
standards is overseen by
an organization called ansi
american national standards institute
everybody calls it ansi
the lack of a federal standard the lack
of a uniform way of going about getting
a standard has created this sort of
vacuum and in that vacuum you know
people see an opportunity to come in and
and serve as experts
[Music]
uh the ceramic tile industry in the
united states put forth a standard with
ansi
at present peter irmish's walkway
management group offers the only tests
to certify people to that industry
standard and so the criticism is that
really they are testing to industry
standard not necessarily to the standard
that would prevent the most amount of
injuries
if you go down the list of laminate
floors luxury vinyl floors
all types of hard surface floors wood
floors
all hard surface floors today really
have no standards even though we've been
publishing ours for decades they will
not voluntarily adopt them in fact the
only
industry that does have a standard is
the ceramic tile industry the tile
council of north america it's a trade
association the tcna is corporate
america on steroids i mean it's the
largest manufacturers in the world who
manufacture ceramic tile who banded
together to create a trade association
who now writes standards for themselves
so it's not my standard or our standard
they adopted the standard that's used in
europe it's the european union standard
recognized by 27 countries
so it's not my standard our role in that
was that we were aware of the research
in europe and we introduced
the tile council leadership to that
research
it's called ansi a326.3
and it defines the test methodology to
determine whether a floor is slippery
and it also
gave us a threshold so you take a
digital numerical measurement
and you can either pass or fail i can
tell you since this methodology has been
commonly used we're not aware of a
single
slip claim that went to trial or even
made it past discovery and the reason
for that is it's so thorough and the
report is so compelling and convincing
that the opposing attorney says you know
i don't think we can win this case
basically we are present in every major
city in the country if you have a
problem or you think you have a problem
you can
call one of our affiliates and they can
measure the problem and they can remove
the problem and they can train your
staff how to keep the floor safe
the cleaning
process should be part of the solution
but often if you use the raw cleaner
you're actually turning a safe lawn into
a slippery floor so
we have to educate the public we're
talking about solving a problem for
sixty dollars
since peter irmish started walkway
management group they said they've
opened 48 franchises
thank you acting commissioner berkel and
fellow commissioners for the opportunity
to speak to you today as part of russell
kenzier's advocacy he has put forward
two petitions before the consumer
product safety commission which is the
federal agency that oversees products
and attempts to prevent injuries his
most recent petition was in 2020 last
year we petitioned them twice
asking that they mandate manufacturers
of floor coverings test and label their
products twice
and lost by a single vote both times and
that was with insurmountable pressure
from all the manufacturers of floor
coverings there was a period where
people could comment and i think the
comments are sort of revealing in and
who
sides with russ people like consumer
advocacy groups and who opposed him
there were other people that sell
tribometers that also felt like uh the
petition was self-interested i can't
tell you how many times i've heard of
course we have a lot of people slipping
and falling russ that's why we have
insurance now you go to the insurance
industry they don't want to hear that
they're paying the claims but as long as
corporate america says well we're just
passing the cost along to the insurance
company and when our premiums go up we
just pass that cost along to you the
consumer
some of the things that russell kenzier
says are not
easy to check but one of the things he
said when i first called him was that
peter when you start calling around
asking people for comment you know
they're going to just say
no thank you goodbye
that was one of the things that did did
in fact check out if you were to contact
any casino any grocery store any large
retail store any hospital and say i'm
doing a story about slips and falls i'd
like to get you know get you behind the
camera and talk about it you won't get a
return call they don't want to talk
about it
but why not i mean it's a big problem
and the reason they don't want to talk
about it is because if they talk about
it that means they know it's a problem
walmart had did not respond to comment
uh costco spokesperson said they had no
comment i contacted cna which is one of
the leading insurers of retailers they
initially agreed to take my questions
but then said
they had no comment
what is the definition of an accident if
you would say well we had an accident on
il3 a lady slipped and fell in some
water well first of all that's not an
accident that's an incident because
accidents are non-predictable and not
preventable from the minute we took our
first steps we all have personal
experience
falling slipping and falling and as we
age that comes back to haunt us elderly
people are just deadly deathly afraid
of slipping and falling they all know
somebody that's in a nursing home or
died had a hip replacement they lost
their life they lost the quality of life
because of a slip and fall so they they
are reluctant to leave the house they
don't want to go out because they're
afraid they might slip and fall what we
want to do is let these people let the
elderly americans live their life live a
full life go out
but that takes commitment that takes
industry commitment manufacturers of
floors have to buy into that message
they don't
[Music]
you